hey I'm Bill Bellamy I'm about to answer
the Internet boom here we go who wins in
a fight ten ten year olds or 100 100
year oh well first of all I'm going with
the one hundred one hundred year olds
gonna win because all they got to do is
just lay on them kids there's a lot of
would you rather have your girlfriend's
hair or your girlfriend hairs in your
hair hmm you know what I might make it
with my girlfriend's hair the world
either losers are women or all sports
which do you choose the world either
loses all the women or all the sports
let me tell you something okay there
ain't no women here
Helen won't be here y'all can kiss my
ass with the sports all right if you
could party with one sports team in
history who would it be
first of all I want to party with the
Chicago Bulls and what would year was
that 92 what was it what year when they
were the six rings the last big
championship no social media Michael
joins the man Dennis Rodman still crazy
I want to just be in that suite who wins
in the streets right Allen Iverson or
y'all mean yo a I'm in my bed but he's
seven feet tall and you five six yeah
would you rather have a threesome with
two female little people or a threesome
with two seven-foot-tall chicks oh my
god Oh like are they are the two little
ones cute yeah I just don't know how
three uh I can be honest with you would
say if it's three
- seven-foot-tall one of them got to
look like Herman a must so I'm just
gonna go with the two little blue bitty
ones I'm gonna go with the two little
boo-boos you get offered a billion
dollars to never leave the state of Ohio
do you take it a billion dollars forever
and I never leave a higher you've been
Ohio you can't do it you're in open
field armed with a baseball bat
mm-hmm how many 10 year-olds wearing
bike helmets could you take them before
they supposed to hit them with it
oh I don't even need a bet I don't need
a bat for 10 year-olds I just push them
now just smack them in the helmet that's
it if you could have any two people
fight in ain't no rules
changement who would you choose some
people no rules that I want to see get
it in who was recently beefing you know
what would be a good one 50 cent and
Floyd Mayweather everybody would see
that that would be an awesome way I
don't know I think I'm gonna go up I'm
gonna go with Floyd cuz he's the boxer
but but 50 would have to get him though
quick would you buy it can you bite I
want to bite would you rather give up
sex or porn for a year if I had to make
the choice I'll just give up porn all
right cuz you because sex is real you
know saying can't get bad for here they
got some new gangster [ __ ] up talk to
you boy see I'm old school I don't even
know the VRC
who is the one celebrity you would want
at your funeral a celebrity
Wow is too many what I would just say
Barack Obama that's gangster would you
rather be the best-looking dude in the
world or be able to read chicks minds
I'm gonna tell you right now I'm already
the best looking do it in the world and
I know how to read chicks - don't even
make sense a [ __ ] would you rather have
a dick no you can not no way can you
answer this right cuz it's all been in
the way you lose you can have your dick
as your nose or your nose as your dick
would you know what time's your nose get
in the way if you can have sex with any
person you want at any time but you can
only watch women's sports forever would
you God you can have sex with anyone in
the world I can never watch basketball
again football is it's only it's only
soccer softball if you can have sex with
anybody in the world anybody anytime you
want it what but you can never watch
male sports again like no basketball or
football or nothing could you do that
that's wrong no I want you know what
i'ma let her stay with you honey I need
sports I can't I can't do without sports
you finale do you think you could beat
any creature on earth armed with two
samurai swords that's gonna be tough a
bear any
oh wow you know a rhino you a rhino with
this is fort you can't be [ __ ] with
samurai force
now if you give me them to ramble guns
though you know the to throw down at me
the one
[ __ ] those swords